hop in yes the 80s Vibe was an intention
it was prevalent in in the jungle
Kingdom and that gorillas wearing a
sports coat I feel underdressed Donkey
Kong kingdom is very high octane a lot
of fun
I would want to go to the Jungle Kingdom
and ride some carts man
wild car chases his entry into the
kingdom is like a roller coaster ride
the driver is just like whatever he's
like having a snack on the way
[Applause]
no big deal we imagined it almost like a
vacation resort in the Bahamas or in
Tahiti giant mountains around volcanoes
secret hideouts built into the mountain
[Music]
I think about the Donkey Kong fight
is a good balance between comedy and
action
the danger was actually that there is no
bottom to that floating in the air Arena
I just want to go to the arena and watch
a fight
Kong's is another day in the donkey
Kingdom